on va dévrifer ensemble il y a eu
bonjour ce matin la matinale de TF1
alors ils nous ont cassé les noisettes
depuis des mois avec cette matinale on
dirait que TF1 ils allaient lancer un
truc de fou frère bon je suis très
content moi j'aime bien Bruce toussin je
préfère Bruce toussin Thomas ato de
loinore Bruce toussin d'habitude on le
voit que pendant les vacances mais là on
le voit tout le temps euh et c'est vrai
que Bruce j'aime beaucoup Thomas Soto je
peux pas le blirer il le sait mais déjà
donc ça me fait une alternative j'aime
bien j'ai bien aimé moi je vous dis la
vérité après ils nous ont bassiné avec
ça pendant des semaines et des semaines
on dirait qu'ils allaient lancer un
prime time tous les soirs tout ce qui
lance en ce moment c'est compliqué pour
TF1 on va pas se mentir tous les
divertissements on voit les deuxième
parti de soirée on voit les prime on
voit les trucs bon c'est compliqué là
ils sont dit on va lancer une matinale
et plus belle la vie donc en fait ils
ont pris la grille à l'envers au lieu de
lancer des trucs forts le soir ils ont
déessayé de lancer des trucs forts le
matin donc au meilleur des cas je vous
dis ça fera 400 500000 téléspectateurs
500 600 600 au meilleurs des cas 600000
je pense voilà donc c'est pas avec ça
que ils vont remonter la chaîne mais bon
ils veulent mettre de l'osille là-dessus
ça à mon avis auamo j'ai regardé je
pense que ça doit coûter je pense comme
ça comme ça au doigts mouillés c'est
100000 le bout il y en a 200 ça fait 20
barres par an 20 million dans la
matinale je sais pas s'il m'ont
récupérer l'oseille mais en tout cas je
leur dis bonjour euh ch non j'aime bien
les gens qui a dedans j'aime bien j'aime
bien les gens qui a dedans je préfère
les gens qui a dedans là que les gens
qui a sur France 2 ouais France 2 c'est
puis le le plateau est beau on VO ouais
et puis a des belles lumièresou puis
après le je pas trop regarder je vais
vous dire euh déjà émission commence
juste avant 7h et heureusement qu'ils
ont un pris générique qui dure tellement
longtemps on dirait un long métrage
[Musique]
regardez
bonjour
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour
bonjour bonjour bonjour et
bonjour dites les amis juste avant qu'on
commence vous êtes sûr que tout le monde
a bien retenu le nom de
[Musique]
l'émission franchement ça
va c'est une version plus jeune de
Télématin pluse plus déjà il ils vont
avoir un public plus jeune que T matin
voilà c'est une bonne alternative au
chaîn info aussi c'est un peu moins
sérieux le fait que ce soit en direct
c'est quand même
[Musique]
bien j'adore Bruce alors je dire moi
j'ai débriefé parce qu'il y a eu quand
même moi j'ai regardé un moment je voula
le dire tout à l'heure je suis tombé sur
le moment le climax de l'émission le
concept de l'émission c'est d'avoir de
nombreux journalistes en duplex c'est
dès 7h13 ils ont une idée génale c'est
d'aller dans une famille pour parler
petit d on va pas se mentir ils nous ont
fait un gros coup de mytho personne n'a
le temps de faire un petit DJ comme ça à
ses enfants les gars faut arrêter les
mecs non mais franchement arrêtez on
sait très bien g Verdez il sort de
Kinder buenau et encore ses enfants ils
ont 46 ans parti regarder ce matin dans
une famille des Alpes Maritimes
direction villeeneuve Loubet près de
Nice Joan Rouquet vous êtes sur place
comment ça se passe le petit déj en
plein petit- dééjeuner ici du côté de
villeeneuve Loubé justement aller voir
la maman qui en train de préparer tout
ça racontez-moi un petit peu qu'est-ce
que vont manger les enfants et votre
mari et vous-même ce matin là j'ai une
omelette pour le grand il va avoir une
pomme vec puis le petit il un grenola
fait maison avec une orange moi je mange
un peu de fruits et mon mari il prend
des tartines au P complet qui fait
luimême
non mais on se fout de la gueule de qui
sans déconner les gars mais franchement
c'est un BR les gars le petit il coûte
100 balles par personne non mais vous
êtes taré ou quoi ils ont envoyé un chef
là-bas non mais ils nous prennent pour
qui sans décon les gars je veux bien je
veux bien tout ce que vous voulez mais
les gars mais arrêtez qui qui fait un
petit com la meuf elle s'est réveillé à
3h du matin frère mais vous êtes des ouf
ou quoi il est 7h3 elle a préparé tout
ça frère la meu arrêtez les gars oh s'il
vous plaît s vous plaî pas moi pas nous
habillé maquillé mais habillé maquillé
fr la meuf la paure elle a pas dormi de
la nuit
mon ils sont partis frère elle était
souougée
voir son
[Applaudissements]
mari ils sont partis voir son Mar avec
cl ils sont partis ces connards je me
coucheer moi je suis B ferme les volets
arrêtez vos conneries là du jour de
attends sans déconner la meuf elle a mis
une tenue de ouf et tout non faut
arrêter les mecs pas à moi c'est à Nouna
là les mecs non on laisse passer parce
que c'est la première mais la prochaine
fois les mec
oh alors c'est extraordinaire qui dit
première étion dit surprise et pour la
première à 7h25 Bruce toussin le
présentateur de l'émission a eu des
messages de ses collègues de TF1 et
notamment un cadeau exceptionnel de la
part d'anclair coudr sans rigoler Dieu
bénisse la TF1 il y a de l'oseille c'est
pas ici regarde regardezuse on avit une
petite surprise pour vous il y a
quelques personnes ici à TF1 qui voulit
vous adresser un message ça vous dit de
regarder ça avec plaisir sacr soiré en
les yeux dans les yeux je voulais
simplement te dire regarde-moi bien
Bruce merde le bonjour du matin nous on
te le dit en disant tout tout simplement
bonjour Merci
Bruce bienvenue dans la famille Bruce je
n'ai pas acheté ton rond de serviette
parce que tu travailles le matin mais
j'avais envie de t'offrir ce joli mug
collec il para que c'est un accessoire
qui va beaucoup de servir dans les mois
qui
[Applaudissements]
viennent et on est passé max du jour
c'est 7h44 c'est là que je suis tombé
làdessus moi je cache pas alors là ils
ont fait fort ils ont été en duplex en
direct d'une famille et de la famille
bonjour ilst dit comme l'émission
s'appelle bonjour on va faire un tuplex
avec une famille qui s'appelle bonjour
et là j'ai dit bon là génie je sais pas
qui est le rédacteur en chef de
l'émission mais je l'embaucherai très
prochainement vraiment je vous dis et à
ce momentl on voit que la technique de
l'émission est aussi éclatée que les
anecdotes j'ai kiffé la famille mais
l'anecdote un peu éclaté au sol regardez
figurez-vous que justement nous sommes
en direct avec une famille bonjour
incroyable direction Villier Morgon
c'est dans le beaujelet c'est bien leur
nom de famille
Pauline
et oui suivez-moi ce matin nous font
l'honneur d'être avec nous pour ouvrir
le bal de cette matinale c'est la
famille bonjour ils sont tous
là difficile à porter comme nom non pas
du tout non non nous sommes très fier
même de notre nom de famille c'est un
peu simple comme bonjour bien sûr il va
de soi voà André vous nous avez parlé
d'une anecdote avec votre grand-père
raconteznous oui quand grand-père est
arrivé donc à l'armée pour la guerre et
bien ils ont été enregistrés et puis de
là le capitaine lui demande son nom et
et lui dit bonjour et la deuxième fois
pareil et trème fois je vous demande pas
de dire bonjour mais je vous demande je
je suis monsieur bonjour et ben voilà
des anecdotes comme ça la famille
bonjour ici elle en a plein est-ce
que est-ce que vous imaginez le matin
fait bon alors toi ma chérie toi tu
partir voir une famille bonjour tu vas
faire un duplex avec une famille bonjour
ah ouais tu es sûr c'est ça que je vais
faire non mais sans déconner et et
c'était fabuleux la famille la famille
et l'anecdote alors demain sachez qu'ils
font la famille au
revoir etc une anecdote éclatée éclatée
au sol total voilà bon après le premier
invité de l'émission c'était Pascal
Obispo bien tu te rends compte
franchement quand on te dit tu vas faire
un live à 9h25 du matin frère je peux te
dire bravo pasan parce qu'il faut avoir
du courage et Pascal B c'est non
seulement un musicien de génie un
chanteur de génie mais c'est aussi un
magicien ce qu'il a réussi un tour de
force c'est de jouer un morceau sur un
piano pas branché regardez sa que c'est
pas évident le matin non mais mais c'est
mais je je je vous ai demandé si vous
accepteriez de vous chanter comment
s'aimer écoutez avec grand plaisir je
vous laisse rejoindre la petite scène je
laisse mes cadeaux là de la
matinale et c'est un vraiment quelque
chose de de très beau et de magnifique
que nous propose Pascal avec cet extrait
de l'album le beau qui pleut comme comm
aim Pascal
[Musique]
Obispo un piano à pile apparemment non
mais les gars le pauvre Pascal Obispo on
dirait qu'il est dans sa chambre sans
char dirait qu'il a sa mère qui va arver
c'est pas fini le bordel là tu vois pas
qu'il y a Tonon qui dort et il y a Télé
Matin comme il s'était vénère qui qui
parce qu' ont volé des gens ouais il y a
un mercato ça veut dire je vous explique
ils ont une mission il y a 16
chroniqueurs ouais euh je v dire ça non
mais ça leur coûte la franchement ça
leur coûte la peau des couilles je vous
dis la vérité là le truc là ça coûte
cher donc je sais pas si c'est moi j'ai
moi j'ai préféré à France 2 je vous dis
la vér mais je sais pas si le jeu envoit
la chandelle voilà si j'avais été patron
de la chaîne je sais pas si je l'aurais
fait voilà après je suis patron de rien
du tout donc je vais fermer ma gueule
mais c'est vrai que voilà Rodolf belmerè
qui est le patron de de TF1 euh
age voilà c'estimage en fait essay de
créer une espèce en fait c'est vrai
qu'il y a une famille par C8 une famille
M6 essayie de créer une famille TF1
parce on sait pas qui c'est les
animateurs de TF1 mais c'est pas parce
qu'il y a la matinale qu'on va mais ils
essay de faire un espèce de groupe de
créer une ambiance je pense c'est pour
ça qu' F ça aussi pour
l'image créer une ambiance moi moi je
parle moi je parle en tant que si
j'étais actionnaire du groupe TF1 moi
quand tu vias venir me voir avec les
chiffres à la fin d'année d'accord ouais
on a perdu 50 millions mais on a créé
une
ambiance bien TR cher l'ambiance tu vas
retourner dans ta chambre là tu vas
arrêter l'ambiance et je veux qu'on
fasse à plus 50 ok g disent qu'on une
famille merci tu es mignon tu es gentil
ouais mais les gens disent qu'on est une
famille j'en ai rien à tu vois
allez vas-y va retravailler là parce que
voilà je connais excuse-moi moi tu sais
moi quand on m'amène moi tu sais je
regarde je regarde juste la ligne à la
fin ok c'est bon merci quand je vois
moins je dis pourquoi on a à moins là et
pourquoi ils font ça selon vous pour
l'audience vous pensez qu'il veulent
faire de l'audience non c'est pour
l'audience c'est pour l'ensemble
l'audience journée parce qu'il perdent
ils perdent à chaque fois sur l'audience
de la journée en fait en fait ce qu'on
regarde c'est la journée par exemple
c'est sachez c'est la première chaîne
TNT sur toute la journée depuis et
d'ailleurs c'était l'année dernière en
2023 on éit première chaîes TF1 il ne
cesse de baisser en audience globale sur
la journée comme le matin ils ont
énormément de difficultés parce qu'ils
mettaient pas d'argent ils mettaient des
des et C qui qui coûtent rien et il y a
un gros problème à la télé en ce moment
c'est que il y a des journalistes en
fait qui vont vous dire ils vont vous
dire demain c'est sûr et certain très
bon démarrage pour bonjour Par que ça a
bien démarré j'ai regardé un petit peu
les indicateurs que j'ai le matin il
font à peu près trois fois ce qu'ils
font d'habitude donc ils vont vous dire
c'est exceptionnel c'est comme j'ai vu
sur sur Camille ou sur Bertrand ou sur
d'autres trucs ils disent à chaque fois
oui ça marche les gars il faut ils
disent ça faisait mieux qu'avant mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'avant il y
avait des redif de série américaine ou
des redifs de trucs qui coûtaient zéro
forcément il faut toujours mais les
journalistes pas voilà ils sont très
sympas il font très bien leur travail
mais on peut pas dire que ce soit des
des gestionnaires donc ce qu'il faut
voir c'est combien ça coûte pour combien
ça rapporte c'est aussi simple que ça
donc moi quand j'ai une case qui fait
800000 qui me coûte zé et qui j'ai une
case qui 850000 mais qui me coûte 150000
semaine je v vous dire mon choix il est
vite fait je dire on va faire la case
qui coûte 0 à 800000 d'accord c'est
simple et là c'est vrai que quand on met
quand on investit sur des programmes il
faut que ça fasse mieux que les
programmes qui nous coûtent zéro donc si
ça si ça si ça augmente de 10 % j'en ai
rien à ce que je veux c'est
savoir combien ça me rapporte là sur la
sur bonjour ça peut booster la chaîne
peut-être le matin mais en plus le matin
il faut que vous sachiez quelque chose
c'est qu'en fait ce qui compte le plus
c'est le 18h 22h c'est ce qui est c'est
comme au bac comme il y avait des
coefficients ça ou pas donc voilà en
fait le matin sur la journée c'est pas
primordiald que ça compte ça compte
voilà donc c'est beaucoup d'argent je ne
sais pas si ça va rapporter c'estàdire
sur une journée globale sachez que TF1 à
peu près ils sont à 18 % voilà ils
étaient à 25 à l'époque et C ils sont à
18 % sur une journée je pense que une
atinale comme ça ça va les faire
progresser peut-être de 03 02 03 donc
est-ce que le jeu envole la chandelle je
sais pas mais en tout cas ça a énervé
télémattin regardez
[Musique]
bonsoir à
tous bonsoir Thomas bonsoir à
tous Bienvenue exactement première de
l'année 2024 on est ravi de vous
retrouver déjà bonne année à vous vous
l'avez déjà entendu mais moi c'est la
première fois je vous le dis voilà donc
ils ont fait vous
avez alors toi qui a fait les matinales
toi PASC tour du qu'est-ce que tu
pensestin de chose je voulais poser une
question la part de marcher le matin
c'est le plus important sur une matinade
le problème c'est que le gâteau il est
tout petit les Français ont pas
l'habitude la diff des États-Unis
institution la matinale les Français ont
pas l'habitude de la regarder c'est
surtout des émissions de d'habitude le
truc c'est que le gâteau il est tout
petit parce que Télé Matin ça fait quoi
700 800 après il y a la matinale de BFM
TV qui aujourd'hui est entre 300 et 400
il va rester quoi pour pour cette
matinale sur le long terme ça c'est la
première chose pour pour faire monter
puis après il va falloir installer
quelque chose parce que la matinale ça
prend du temps les habitudes de
consommation les gens ils appent pas le
matin c'estàdire que ils sont là avec
les enfants c'est comme la radio on a
des un oui mais ça peut monter à combien
ça c'est ma
première bon ils vont jamais et après il
faut créer quelque chose parce que ce
que j'ai vu ce matin bon alors Bruce moi
c'est quelqu'un que j'appréciead voilà
professionnellement voilà il est très
classe moi c'est l'un des seuls qui m'a
envoyé un petit SMS quand je suis parti
de BFM TV avant qu'il qu'il ne s'en
aille lui aussi il est très élégant et
c'est quelqu'un qui a cette cette
bonomie il va il va savoir porter porter
l'équipe mais moi ce que j'ai vu ce
matin ça fait 15 ans matinal j'en ai
fait 15 ans j'ai vu beaucoup de choses
qui ont déjà été vu le présentateur
météo dehors
B la famille au petitdéjeuner aussi vair
inventer quelque chose et ça c'est un
peu difficile pour se démarquer des
autres matinales ilmar avec les régions
déjà par
rapport
vaarqu
TR a un problème de chroniqueur quand
même disent rien ils font rien ils font
leur chronique aucune
interactionist be qui le fait un pe
mais n'existe pas ça va venir ça il
connaissent ils se connaissent à peine
moi j'attends de voir les autres parce
que là heureusement qu'il faisait froid
aujourd'hui parce que il ne parlait que
de la météo à toute l'émission c'était
le fil conducteur ça m'a vraiment marqué
je me suis dit s'il faisait pas froid
qu'est-ce qui se serait passé ah ouais
la photo tu as drôle de problème à 7h4
ben non mais c'est
vrai
t' moi j'ai rien regardé je suis arrivé
à 7h44 je suis tombé sur ce bail là j'ai
dit quel coup de chance je suis
tombé sur la famille bonjour j'ai dit
bon ben c'est bon rideau merci je me
suis recouché frère c'est bon j'ai dit
vas-y ils me réveilleront demain allez